[Music]
last time you were here you were
promoting wreck-it ralph yes and uh i
think you were here just before the
movie came out then it becomes one of an
instant classic
everyone goes crazy for the movie what's
it like for you now when kids meet you
are they excited that you're the
wreck-it ralph guy well if they're older
than eight years old yes
because
i realize now there's a cutoff in
perceptual
intelligence with children
where if you're older than eight you
realize like actors do the voice and
then cartoonists make the cartoons
i often have parents come up to me like
with like a four-year-old like billy do
you know who that is like it's wreck-it
ralph
and the kid's like
no
oh why are my parents lying to me
why
this band is not record round it looks
nothing like recognition it doesn't have
green overalls on like and then then
i'll get kind of desperate like uh
i'm gonna wreck it like
that's not how it sounds
i know i i do it different in the movie
but trust me kid it's me
anyway i feel bad
but yes i'm i've been implanted in
children's brains all over the world
thanks to disney yeah very nice that's
their masterpiece
yeah you
you uh you started performing as a kid
like you liked it right away when you
were a kid didn't you yeah well
i was kind of a delinquent kid and then
i found this drama class or drama class
as we used to call it in my neighborhood
in chicago in chicago they say drama
drama john you going to drama yeah
[Laughter]
stop by grandma's on the way back from
drama yeah real dramatic yeah um
anyway i went over to this like field
house of the park and they had this
after school thing called drama
and uh the teacher was like okay
everybody we're gonna we're gonna just
do some different stuff now like we're
gonna explore some things so i want
everyone to lie down on the floor okay
and you're lying on the floor and then
he starts going okay you're a piece of
bacon
all right
now i'm gonna turn on the gas
and what happens to a piece of bacon
when it cooks it's and all of us are
like on the floor like
sizzling and i realized like i found my
calling
those people
this is what i want yeah most people
would be like what i'm getting out of
here this is weird and i was like my
people
and i love bacon and you love who
doesn't love bacon were you a good
student
uh good by meaning totally average yeah
like
good meat i thought i thought of school
as like
like a day job like you do your best
but let's face it it's just work you're
gonna do the fun stuff after school
so to me like a c was like the best
you know you would aim for a c oh yeah
often fell short of a c but
like if you got a d you'd get in trouble
but like to me like an a was like way
overkill like what
i'm not working that hard like yeah
i just want to get through this so i can
go on and do the fun things like
yeah so b minus every once in a while to
like have something to brag about you
know like
in a subject that i was already really
good in like spelling or something you
know
so you get a b minus you'd be like check
this out yeah exactly and then it'll be
like they'd be like what about the d
plus it's a plus
i focus on the b focus
i gotta go i'm gonna be bacon now i
gotta get out of here exactly don't
worry i'm gonna grow up and be bacon
that's what parents like to hear